- Good morning, believe nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael,
and my one word is believe,
and I believe that
entrepreneurs will solve
all of the major problems in the world.
So to help you on your journey today,
we're going to talk
about how you can create
a massive action plan.
Rule number three is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always, as you're
watching, if you hear something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it down
in the comments below,
put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired.
You might win a prize too.
And also, when you write it
down, it's much more likely
to stick, for yourself, as well.
Enjoy.
(Upbeat pop music)
- Some of you, in the past,
you've gotten momentum,
you've gotten passionate,
you've even made a decision,
but a decision is the first step.
Decision is like a war.
I got to do this or that, alright,
I'm going to make myself do this.
But commitment is when you
now, after you've decided,
you commit to do this for the long-term.
Whether it's hard or easy doesn't matter.
You're doing this.
It takes it from this moment,
and it carries it into the future,
even when things are difficult.
Then once you decide, the
only way the commitment
and the energy, and the
momentum, continues,
is if you take immediate,
massive, what, my friends?
Massive what?
Write down in your notes, massive action
is the cure-all.
Massive action is the cure-all.
If you're having a difficult
time with something,
your relationship isn't
where you want it to be, your
finances are not where
you want to be, your body
is not where you want to be, your business
is not where you want to be,
you need to take massive action.
And if that doesn't
work, try something else.
If that doesn't work, try something else.
Keep going with massive action,
and you will find the way, because
it will give you momentum.
(light bell music)
When it comes to planning your life,
I want to get you to learn
to ask three questions now,
and the first one is not:
what am I going to do?
And how many understand why now, say I.
- [Audience] I.
- The question you want to ask
yourself is: what do I want?
What's my outcome, what's my result?
The word R-P-M, the first one
is to get you focused on the target.
The target is not the activity,
the activity can change.
It's, what's the result I'm after?
If you know exactly what
it is you really want,
what you desire, what you're really after,
clarity is power.
The more clear you are in
specifically what you want,
the faster your brain can get you there.
But if you're genuinely saying
things like: what do I want?
Well, I want more money.
Fine.
Here's a dollar, get out of here.
(audience laughing)
Did you achieve the outcome?
Yeah.
When you're that general,
you think you're not
getting your goal, you are.
The way you language your
goal, the way you think
about it, you're receiving it.
You know, I want to feel a bit better.
I want to lose some weight.
Fine, you lost a pound, you're done.
'Cause your brain's
like a servo mechanism,
and a bomb, and a missile.
The old days, you shoot a missile,
and the target was going, and
if you missed the trajectory,
you missed it.
Today, what happens when the missile
is not on course, what happens?
It locks on to the heat
signature, what does it do?
It moves and follows it.
That's the way your brain
is, if it knows the outcome,
if it knows the result.
So RPM starts with, I
got to know the result,
this is a results planning system.
The rapid planning method, you can think
of it as a results planning system.
I need to know the result I'm after,
before I ever ask myself what to do.
That takes more time,
but it's worth it.
And when you think in terms
of outcomes and activities,
pretty soon, some of the
activities, you'll notice,
you don't even need to
do to get the outcome.
You'll find a better way to
get the outcome, quicker.
Now, how do you do that?
You ask three questions.
Question one: what is my result?
What is my outcome?
What is it that I really,
truly want from this?
If you're going back next week,
and you say this next week,
what are the most important, what?
Outcomes, for me to get
this week, in my business.
And you just write those outcomes out,
not your action items, the outcomes.
If you do that and nothing else,
you'll be ahead of the game.
And if you just keep looking
at those outcomes every day.
How am I doing on that outcome?
Your brain will come up with
ways to get to that outcome,
I promise you.
Focus on the outcomes, not on activities.
Action, for most people, activities,
most people mistake
movement for achievement.
They mistake action items
and to-do's for achievement.
We're after the achievement.
Are you with me on this?
Yes or no.
- [Audience] Yes.
- It's a different way of thinking,
and I think all of you
inherently have it, but if you
make this ritualized, just
like the things you've learned
this week, they're all great,
but if you don't systematize them,
they'll work when you do 'em.
Why is more important than how.
Why are we doing this?
What's the purpose?
Purpose is more powerful than object.
You say I want a million dollars.
That's a great objective.
I want a billion dollars, great objective.
I want to feed 3,000
children in my community,
that's a beautiful objective,
it's even more specific.
But even that objective,
you might get excited
about, 'till you realize what
it takes to feed 3,000 kids.
Right?
And the politics involved,
and all the people
that don't follow through.
And then you have this good intention,
and somebody else is pissed off because
one of the kids didn't get fed.
(audience laughing)
Right?
And you didn't even know
what you're going to do.
What's going to make you keep going?
Purpose.
Why do we want to feed those 3,000 kids?
Why do you want to make
that million dollars,
that billion dollars?
Why do you want to take your
business to the next level?
Why is the most important thing to know,
'cause that's where all the
emotional juice and fuel
is, to actually get you to go through
when the challenges show up.
Every person you see who's
on fire and is successful,
knows the why.
You know what the problem is?
You might know the why at the beginning,
you wrote a mission statement
and stuff like that.
You got to know why you're
doing this, right now.
This, right now.
That's what's going to engage
you and activate the why.
You might have a why, but it's not active.
80% of success is why, 20% is how.
Get a big enough why, people
will figure out how to do it.
And once you know the why,
you know what you're after
and why, then the question
is: how do we do it?
We know what we're after
and why; how do we do it?
By the way, are there lots of
how's to get to an outcome?
Yes or no.
- Yes.
- Are there many paths
to get a result, yes or no?
- Yes.
- Some are more efficient than others,
and you're not going to know, so you know
what you do, you brainstorm
out all the how's you can think of.
All of things you could possibly need
to do to get that result,
and then you narrow it down to the 20%
that makes 80% of the difference, and
you'll find out you don't have
to do that whole to-do list.
If fact, wouldn't it be nice
to write your own to-do list
and not do it, and still get the outcome?
(audience laughing)
How many would prefer that?
Say I.
- [Audience] I.
- That's RPM.
I love it when I don't do my
to-dos, and I get the outcome.
That's the coolest thing in the world.
You might have done one or two of them,
but it's then learning selectively
which ones are going to
create it, but the only one
you got to brainstorm out, the
M, the massive action plan.
So if you know the result,
and you know the purpose,
now you need the M, which
is the massive action plan.
We also call the massive
action plan, the MAP.
It's your massive action plan, your map.
How are you going to get there?
What are you going to do?
And by the way, when you're
crystal-clear in what you want,
and you know why you want
it, you can make a big map.
You can brainstorm a
million ways to do it.
Not all your how's are going to work,
that's why you make a whole map.
And then go back and
gradually asterisk the ones
that are the most
important, and go hit those.
You might get the whole
outcome in the first two
action items, and get rid of
the whole rest of your list.
This is RPM.
This is how I operate.
Now, if you never did this on paper,
and you just did this
thinking process in your head,
you'll get invaluable resources.
If you learned to put this on paper,
it'll be more powerful
because then your brain
isn't racing, and you can see it.
If you make it into a system
that you personally use,
your productivity will explode.
If you teach your whole
company to do this,
your company will go up
levels you can't even imagine,
'cause everyone will
maximize their productivity.
- Large uninterrupted blocks of time,
you have to schedule,
if you are a creator.
Blocks of time that are at
least two to four hours,
or more, in length.
No Frankenstein monster
of 20-minute breaks
and 10-minute breaks,
combined into three hours,
will have the value of
an uninterrupted block
of three hours
if you are trying to make
high-level decisions,
focus on time-consuming,
high-priority projects,
push something to a next milestone,
as a maker, creator.
We all have the same 24 hours in the day,
and if you're like, I don't have time,
I can't sleep, I need
to cut back on sleep,
I need to do this, I need to do that,
if you don't have time,
you don't have priorities.
That's it.
- Writing in a journal allows you
to record your daily progress.
There's a lot of scientific research
on the small win theory.
And what it says is this:
if every single day,
you record small daily acts of progress,
you actually dump dopamine,
a neurotransmitter, into your brain,
and that is a great source of motivation.
You feel happy and you feel strong,
and you feel inspired.
So every single morning,
in your holy hour,
from five to six, take 20 minutes,
record your wins of the
previous day, in your journal.
It'll keep you motivated,
it'll make you feel
like you're making progress,
it'll keep you inspired,
versus always feeling like
you're never achieving enough.
- What do you suggest, Mel,
for accessing what you really want?
You know, I talk a lot about
being honest with yourself
about what you want,
and if you're somebody
that's watching this and you
have no clue what you want,
I'm going to say that's total bull.
I think you've probably
decided that either
you can't have it, because you don't think
you're smart enough or good
enough, or worthy enough,
or maybe you think you're too old,
or you've told yourself
that you can't make a living doing it.
Both are complete and utter lies
that you're telling yourself.
What you need to do is ask yourself this:
if you took money off the table,
if you didn't give a what
anybody else thought,
what's the thing you would love
to be doing with your life?
Seriously.
Do you dream of being a
professional photographer?
Do you want to open your own restaurant?
Have you always thought
about traveling the world
and entertaining kids
with your juggling skills?
I don't know, it's your life.
You get to choose what you want to do.
Be honest with yourself.
What is it that you would
want to do with your life,
if you didn't have to
pay the bills doing it?
Another thing you can ask yourself:
who do you find yourself
sort of envious of?
You know, like you look at their life,
and you just think, gosh, how awesome
that they get to do that.
Well once you have that
answer for yourself,
you've gotten really
honest, you've pushed the
aside, and you've really
asked it for yourself
and answered the question honestly,
all you got to do is
explore it, that's it.
Just find one thing that
you can do to enrich
and expand your knowledge
about it, find one course
online, Google the topic, stalk people
that are pursuing this line of work.
That's how you start to do it.
One step at a time.
So start with answering the question,
what do you really want, with
a massive dose of honesty,
Google the topic, and find one thing
that you can do, just one.
Push yourself, and start to explore.
If you were to wake up and
do that every single day,
spend 10 minutes a day,
you would be startled,
astonished by what your life looks like
in a matter of a year or two.
- Never lose hope.
That you have a single breath
within your body right now,
and that you are alive
in this moment, is hope.
That you can see all these
people walking on the street,
smiling, is hope.
That all these entrepreneurs
are posting their art
online, every single day
now, there is hope there.
That there is a single
person out in this world
whose soul is still burning alive
with love, is hope.
You know, it's so easy during these days,
when sometimes there's
darkness, when you see
all this negative media coverage,
or maybe you have a series of bad days,
or a series of bad weeks,
or your lucky break just isn't coming,
or you've been fighting for that dream,
you just don't sense any of that progress
that you just so need
to feel still enlivened,
and engaged, and
enthusiastic about something,
or somebody breaks up with
you, or you lose your job,
or something happens with your health.
Look, that's part of life,
is there's going to be so many
struggles and disappointments,
challenges, set-backs, dark days.
And part of sustaining, and
making through all of that
is maintaining hope,
and that hope isn't something
that just, you know,
some airy-fairy concept.
It is a psychological need
to believe that we can endure,
a psychological need to believe
that we can not only
endure, but we can succeed
and we can thrive, and we
can have our way in the world
so that we can accomplish our dream,
so that we can make influence,
make our own difference.
So, have hope, but even as I say that,
let me reconfigure that
statement and that phrase,
because too many people
say well you have hope
or you can lose hope,
but hope isn't something actually
you have or that you lose,
even though we say that phrase
at such a popular level.
You know, years ago, a
metaphor came into my life,
that changed my life forever.
It changed my attitude and my actions,
and how I thought about life,
and frankly, how I felt every
single moment of the day.
It was something that lifted
me to a whole 'nother level
of joy and vibrancy in life,
and it was this very simple metaphor
that the power plant doesn't have energy,
it transforms and generates energy.
Let me say that again.
The power plant doesn't have energy,
it transforms and generates energy.
At the same level, we don't
quote-unquote have hope,
we transform the energy around us,
we generate hope.
We don't have happiness,
we generate happiness.
Similarly, we don't
have sadness or fatigue,
we don't have those feelings
that so many people think
are negative, that just land on them.
We are in our own
actions, our own thoughts,
our own interpretations,
the very thoughts that we
are feeding our psyche.
Those very things, those
are generating an emotion,
and hope is something
that is generated by us.
When it feels like it is gone,
that becomes a to-do list for
us to generate it once more,
just like when your phone is dying,
you plug it in to charge it up.
Well, when your hope is dying,
it's time to generate it
and charge it up again.
Same thing with happiness, and aliveness,
and enthusiasm, those are things,
when they're going down,
you got to get focused,
you got to plug back in to your passions,
to your dreams, to tomorrow,
to charge yourself back up again.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know, what did
you think of this video?
What did you take from it that
you're going to immediately
apply to your life, or
to your business somehow?
Please share, leave it
down in the comments below.
I'm really excited to
see what you have to say.
I also want to give a quick shout-out
to Attraverso Marketing.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
"Your One Word", and sharing the post
that I made on Twitter about it.
I really appreciate the support,
and I hope you enjoy the read.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you continue
to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is.
Much love, have an amazing
day, and I'll see you soon.
- In describing your values, you prefer
to use verbs over nouns.
Now, why is this the case?
And, what verbs do you
use to describe yourself?
- So, values have to be verbs.
It's not that I like them to be verbs,
it's that they have to be verbs,
and the reason is because
values are things you do.
Values are things you live
by, and you can't do nouns.
You can only do verbs.
And so, if you look at an
organization, for example,
you see companies that
have their corporate values
on the wall, and it says innovation,
respect, honesty, right?
(laughing)
- [Interviewer] Some
nice posters there too,
I'm sure.
- Yeah, beautiful posters.
And if you have to write
honesty on the wall,
you've got bigger problems, you know?
But you can't do innovation.
You can't walk into
someone's office and say,
from now on, please, a
little more innovation
in all that you do.
But you can say, look at the world
from a different perspective,
instead of innovation.
Instead of honesty, you
can say do the right thing.
You can hold people accountable to that.
You can create measurements around that.
And when somebody says,
you know, were you honest?
You're like, well yeah, but you know,
it was more profitable.
You know, you can sort of
sneak around it, whereas
if somebody says did
you do the right thing?
It's a higher standard.
And so, you have to have
verbs if you want to do them.
So, my values are take an
unconventional perspective,
keep it simple, share,
I believe in sharing
everything, sharing ideas,
sharing experiences, silver line it, and
what I mean by that is
I find a silver lining
in every cloud.
The goal is not to try and fix
the things that are broken,
the goal is to try and
amplify the things that work.
And ultimately, one of the goals
is make long-term progress.
And because that is a
stated value, a stated
way of operating,
and it is a verb, I focus on measuring
the long-term value that
I can create in the world,
and not just the short-term gains.
- First, you sit or lie in a quiet place
where you can be completely
alone in the silence.
Through positive affirmations,
imagine yourself going through
an important upcoming experience,
such as a meeting, a presentation,
a negotiation, or even a date,
that would improve your work-life balance
and your quality of life.
As you sit or lie completely relaxed,
create a picture of the coming event
and see it unfolding
perfectly in every respect.
See yourself as calm, positive, happy,
and in complete control.
See the other people doing and saying
exactly what you would want them
to do if the situation was perfect.